así es un golpe a la justicia de la
unión europea el tribunal constitucional
polaco confirmó por abrumadora mayoría
que las leyes polacas tienen prioridad
sobre las europeas algo que va en contra
de los tratados de adhesión que el país
firmó que especifican que las leyes de
bruselas tienen prioridad sobre las
nacionales desde el partido gobernante
sin embargo justifican la defensa de la
soberanía
en polonia la legalidad más alta que
también rige los actos de la unión
europea es la constitución social decir
lo contrario significaría que en primer
lugar polonia no es un estado soberano y
en segundo que no existe democracia en
polonia
diez de los catorce miembros de este
tribunal fueron elegidos por el partido
ultraconservador la injusticia en una
intromisión denunciada desde bruselas y
desde la oposición polaca que ya
advierte de la posibilidad de un pol
exit es decir una posible salida de la
nación del bloque comunitario
somos guardianes de los tratados a nivel
de la comisión y haremos lo que sea
necesario para tratar de lograr una
correcta aplicación de los tratados
ese es el principal objetivo de este
tribunal salió la ley más restrictiva
con el aborto de toda la unión europea
algo que provocó en numerosas
manifestaciones a principios de 2021
además otros colectivos como el lg ven
que sin el poder de bruselas la
regresión total de sus derechos puede
estar más cerca